we've done a lot of work so far on
weather scenarios for San Francisco and
for Los Angeles I've put forward to you
this probability model some of you say
it's not very realistic quite right this
is a teaching example these are the
probabilities because they suit me and
that's what I say they are but what we
did last time was to say if you're
worried that these could get distorted
in transmission what's the best thing to
do what's the easiest thing to do well
the easiest thing to do I introduced you
to this idea of a checksum digit at the
end what it meant was that as long as
only any one of these bits got distorted
in transmission you had a lovely
situation of if you like good codes but
if you said mmm one bit gets distorted
as long as he's having one bit out of
the three you could end up with
something like this zero becoming a one
you've received zero one zero that's not
in the list of valid codes there's an
error has happened there and I think I
covered also the fact that you may know
that there is an error there this could
arise in two or three different ways but
you don't know how it occurred but at
least it's nice to know there's an error
did occur and at the very end of the
last discussion we said well if you want
to say to San Francisco I didn't receive
your data correctly you could send
either an ACK knowledge or a not
acknowledge signal and I've postulated
to you that we might decide that an
acknowledge signal to send back to San
Francisco meaning I got your three bit
code it makes sense to me I got zero
zero zero it's foggy wonderful I like it
if that is the case send like a zero on
the other hand if I received a zero one
zero it's not in this allowed set of
codes I would send back was technical an
ACK and we'd use a one bit for that many
of you said what would happen if these
acknowledgement codes got clobbered on
their way back to San Francisco how on
earth would you then cope
well armed with what we know now the
simple approach instead of acknowledge
being a single zero we'll make it a
double zero instead of not acknowledged
being a 1 let's make it a double one if
one of these gets altered you might get
a 1 0 you might get a 0 1 similarly here
if just one bit of those gets altered
you could equally end up with 0 1 or
with 1 0 you expect if you're back in
San Francisco do we say a clean double
zero or a clean double one if you get
these you know that an error has
occurred in transmission but as ever you
don't know how it occurred was it a
distorted acknowledged signal or a
distorted not a noisy signal now this
could go on forever if we're not careful
you know San Francisco sending back to
Sacramento I've got a not acknowledged
on your attempted acknowledge signal you
just it's not good what you really like
to do here and this is a very useful
lead-in for me to lead into Hamming
codes let's see how we can build up a
slightly more sophisticated system
adding one extra bit more if you do that
you can not only detect that an errors
occurred but you can actually correct it
this gentleman Richard Hamming comes
slightly after I think the person I
mention already the great god father of
information theory Claude Shannon so
those are the two big names around about
this era shortly after the information
theory and optimal codes and so on but
in noiseless conditions Claude Shannon
few years later comes Richard Hamming
saying how can we detect errors and more
to the point how could we begin to
correct to them you've put this on a
plate for me because I can discuss it in
terms of how to get an AK and an AK back
to San Francisco so that you can decide
and correct it if it gets clobbered from
now on the AK will be to send three
zeros the nak
we'll be to send three ones suppose you
send three why is that magic what does
it do if it's a three bit pattern that
you're sending then if those get varied
for any reason of noise the total number
of combinations in three bits as we know
off by heart now it's due power three
eight combinations
let me just pluck out of thin air the
idea of representing those eight
combinations possible as being the
corners of a cube let me not go through
the algorithm for creating Hamming code
but just pluck it out of thin air cuz
I'm so fond of doing let's call this one
up here
oh good code of zero zero zero let's
call this one at the back lower corner
of the cube one one so that one if you
like is representing act this one is
representing Mac so so long as your
properties of your line were such that
errors were relatively infrequent and
you got mostly one binary digit errors
then fine here's what would happen you
might send zero zero zero and it ended
up as being received has zero one zero
the middle bit got damaged you might
send a one one one and it got received
as a woman zero a one got into a zero
you might for example have sent three
zeros but I represent over here at the
left hand they got hit and became
looking like a one is 101
this one is 0:01 and this one down at
the bottom is o1 one
let me just circle these are what was
actually transmitted so can you see that
what you're now in the lovely position
have been able to
if I receive three zeros that's bound to
be good
similarly if you receive one one one
trust it it's an AK but if you receive a
zero one zero what then should you do
the rule is maximum likelihood if I can
spell that night or nearest-neighbor
correction you can correct what you've
received by saying on the following I
received a zero one zero I know that
that is not on my list of good code
words plus the only good ones are three
zeros and three ones what's the most
likely way to correct zero one zero back
into being something good
well the answer is by going up this line
here this distance one away I changed
the middle bit back to a zero and I've
corrected it to three zeros if I receive
zero zero one the most likely thing
that's happened with only one error
taking place is that the trailing zero
here got damaged into a Wong so my
correction should be like this go
distance one along the cubes edges like
that 100 corrects back to three zeroes
now same thing again look the majority
of the bits here one one zero two out of
three match up with one one one there
for my best and most likely correction
is to turn the zero back into a one
how about 101 oh yeah obviously this was
sent and it was the middle bit that got
hit and turned into a zero so correct
that one down here finally over here
zero one one again two-thirds of the
bits are correct but the leading one got
hit and turned into a zero I clearly
have to correct to that so you can see
looking at that that for all of the six
corners of the cube that are not the
good undamaged codes you have with
nearest neighbor maximum likelihood
correction a distance one correction
algorithm but the final thing to notice
is that for this to work and you may
remember going back to my original
example of when you can detect but you
can't correct the thing there was at the
distance between the good codes was to
notice that what we're doing here now is
that between these good codes actually
use yet another color if you want to get
from 0 0 0 to 1 1 1 you have got to take
a journey involving one two three steps
don't matter how you get there you could
go one two three
you could go one two three down there
the good codes are distance three apart
so this is the simplest example I can
think of of what was generalized by
Richard Hamming into being Hamming codes
the way you actually build them up our
algorithmically is a bit involved but
I'll let you all look up about this if
you want some more information
essentially Hamming codes are really
really good and absolutely definitive in
their time for doing distance one
Corrections okay for coping with things
where only one bit was in error where
things get massively mathematical
utterly fascinating and deeply involved
are the moment you start saying oh well
I'd like to correct one bit but not just
in a three bit pattern how about in a 32
bit pattern yeah okay well how many
different ways can that go wrong and how
are we going to keep all of these
different one bit errors apart from one
another how can we keep the good codes
well apart in a much bigger big bit
pattern and where things get really
hilariously hairy is if you say mm I
don't want to correct just one bit I
want to correct three bits up to four
bits up to seven bits and that gets you
seriously involved in stuff with names
like field theory rings groups cosets
another lovely stuff like that
thought we do is make them all sort
hundred elements and see the
side-by-side sped up a bit at some other
quite slope I did all the compute in
business we're free to select from the
different games that happen to have the
cabinet design is based on the genuine
defender arcade machine developed by
Williams in 1980 this was written over a
weekend